-Happy holidays.
-Thank you. To you, as well.
-Thank you. Your family --
you went to the Caribbean.
-We did.
We went somewhere tropical,
Turks and Caicos.
-Beautiful.
-Missed the Turks,
but we went to the Caicos.
-Oh, that's nice. Yeah.
They say make sure
you hit the Caicos.
-The Caicos' the best.
-I spent it in New Mexico.
We've talked about this before.
You and my wife are both
from the Albuquerque area
of New Mexico.
So you did not go back at all?
-I was not in the land
of enchantment.
-Although, I really do like
going back for Christmas.
-It's beautiful.
-It's super beautiful.
It's super tranquil and flat,
they have the luminarias.
You know those?
These are small brown lunch bags
filled with sand and then a
little candle
that's on the inside of them.
And they light them.
And you put them all around.
-When you start,
it doesn't sound like
it's gonna end beautiful.
You're like, "It's the most
beautiful thing.
It's a lunch bag..."
[ Laughter ]
"...and you fill it with sand."
-And then you light it on fire
and then you --
-And then you ring the doorbell.
-But when they're all around,
they're really quite beautiful.
-It is a very beautiful place.
-How long were you there?
-I was there for 12 days.
-Oh! That's a long time.
-It was with my in-Laws
who I love dearly.
12 days is a lot of days.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a lot of days
in any place.
-Yeah, it really --
I think that's it,
'cause I don't want this
to be about my in-laws,
it's just a lot of days
in any place.
-You probably chose that because
you have small children.
-I didn't choose.
I don't make the choice.
[ Laughter ]
-I've done New Mexico
for the holidays,
it's fun, but I like
for the New Year's,
I like top to be
somewhere warm.
-Yes. I think that's --
And I think we should clarify.
A lot of people, if you say
you're going to New Mexico,
they say,
"Oh, at least it's warm."
It's not warm.
-Not in the wintertime, no.
It's freezing.
-It's freezing, yeah.
That's why the old Mexico
has them beat by far.
-Oh, maybe that's why people
think you're talking about --
-Yeah.
-The New Mexico.
It's like they've rebranded
themselves.
-They're like, "Oh, my God."
-It's actually a state
in the nation, Mr. Trump.
-Yeah. I'm going to
the New Mexico.
It's amazing.
It's like super Cancun.
[ Laughter ]
But it is beautiful, and I --
another thing -- this show is
a beautifully shot show.
-"Series of Unfortunate Events?"
-Yeah! It's just gorgeous.
-Or your show?
-This is beautiful.
All the more so when you're here
and you're beautiful --
No, but this is so gorgeous and
it's so funny,
and well-made and three seasons.
It's wrapping up.
Are you happy with
how it finished?
-I'm sincerely just super
proud of the show.
When it came to me, I was
excited by the idea
that it was just covering
the canon of these 13 books,
the "Series of Unfortunate
Events" books,
so it wasn't supposed to
be a series that went on
for seasons and seasons.
It was just three
seasons all in.
Barry Sonnenfeld, who is
spectacular and eccentric
and amazing, has this really
great vision.
And I got to wear crazy
prosthetics, the cast was good,
Netflix gives you lots of money
to create it,
and then they back off and allow
you the opportunity
to just create a piece of art.
So the fact that it wasn't just
"Let's hope we can get,
you know, another season
or two out of it,
but that we did this piece
of art, in my opinion,
that can go on a shelf, and the
shelf now being streaming media,
with Netflix,
if you haven't seen the show,
you can go and start at
season one, episode one,
and you can watch it.
It's for young adults,
it's for adult adults.
-And it's a timeless
show that was --
It's timelessly made.
It'll be as good in ten years
as it was now,
which is really exciting
as well.
-That's what I think is cool.
It's different than trying --
on television in the past,
at least for me,
you're hoping that people
keep watching
so you can keep doing it,
and you're really just trying
to sort of squeeze
the sponge dry.
But this didn't feel that way.
I was just really proud of the
way it turned out.
So the third season, the final
season, just started
what January 1st, and you can
watch all of the episodes.
And it's rad. I'm proud of it.
-You mentioned prosthetics.
Your character also had a tattoo
and then you posted a photo
that makes it seem like you
maybe got the actual tattoo.
-I did.
-You did?
-Oh, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, yeah.
-Is that your -- is that
a first-time tattoo?
-No. I get a tattoo for every
big, long series that I do.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Yeah. For "How I Met
Your Mother" I got
the picture of the mother...
-Oh, that's -- Yeah, right.
-...tattooed on my scalp.
-Oh, so if you ever shaved
your head -- yeah.
-Look.
-Oh, that's the mother.
-Yeah.
-There you go.
-Yeah, well for "Dr. Horrible,"
I had Captain Hammer
tattooed on the length
of my dong.
-Uh...
[ Laughter ]
I heard about that.
I did hear about that.
-Yeah.